[Musique]
car oui c'est la capitale canadienne des
énergies fossiles toutes les grandes
entreprises ils ont établi ces aides
sociales ici personne ne prévoit la fin
du pétrole et des sables bitumineux à
court ou moyen terme
les marchés émergents en chine et en
inde reçoivent de pétrole et de gaz
naturel soutient t mecque médine mieux
vaut produire du pétrole selon les
standards canadiens play de l'industrie
mais les
avocats
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant que tout
le secteur n'est pas déterminé à réduire
ses émissions dans son laboratoire de
l'université de calgary yang et étudier
à temps plein différentes façons de
réduire l'empreinte écologique de la
production pétrolière
en alberta ont fait le pari d'augmenter
la production tout en réduisant son
empreinte carbone un défi titanesque les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
produites par l'industrie pétrolière et
gazière ont augmenté de 87% de 1990 à
2006 9 à lui seul le secteur représente
26 % de toutes les émissions au canada
les gros joueurs se sont récemment
engagés à devenir carboneutre d'ici 2050
mais même avec l'avancée de technologies
comme la capture et la séquestration du
carbone produire un baril de pétrole
carboneutre n'est pas pour demain
pour l'alberta le défi reste donc entier
impossible pour l'instant de réduire les
émissions de ges sans freiner un des
principaux moteurs économiques
économiste chef le voit beaucoup de
turbulences dans l'horizon de la
province
et les décisions les plus difficiles
restent encore à prendre si le canada
veut atteindre ses cibles de réduction
de ges
loin des débats politiques des
laboratoires et des sièges sociaux en
alberta l'enjeu de la transition
énergétique touche d'abord et avant tout
des centaines publie travailleurs biais
pays
à cause de leur ai dit est opérateur
technique à la raffinerie impérial
denton il reconnaît que le monde change
et que l'industrie doit s'adapter au
changement climatique
mais il voudrait que la voix des
travailleurs comme lui se retrouve
davantage au coeur des débats sur la
transition
27 à lui déjà dans l'industrie depuis
huit ans il ne regrette pas son choix de
carrière y croit dans l'avenir du
secteur
[Musique]
accomplir avec succès une transition
énergétique aura de vastes conséquences
partout au canada mais c'est d'abord
surtout en alberta que cette profonde
transformation aura un impact ici
atteindre lycée climatique n'auriez
d'abstrait ici mais dessus cueilli radio
canada
l'alberta compte dont 34 sièges en 2019
les libéraux ont été rayés de la carte
électorale les conservateurs ont
remporté 33 circonscriptions sur 34 et
le npd une en saskatchewan ça a été un
balayage complet 14 sièges pour les
troupes conservatrices et au manitoba
c'était plus divisé 7 sièges pour les
conservateurs quatre pour les libéraux
et trois aux néo démocrates alors à quoi
s'attendre le 20 septembre les libéraux
peuvent ils espérer une percée je joins
à edmonton frédéric boily il est
professeur de sciences politiques au
campus saint-jean de l'université de
l'alberta bonsoir monsieur boily besoin
alors on vient de le voir là dans le
reportage le pétrole c'est vraiment un
enjeu incontournable en alberta
oui absolument incontournable il faut
que les partis politiques se
positionnent effectivement par rapport à
ça évidemment les conservateurs depuis
longtemps appuyé fortement
cette industrie cela dit il y a quand
même un changement je dirais dans la
perception générale quant à l'avenir de
ce secteur c'est à dire que oui on s'en
tint me jouer même du côté des libéraux
et de certains néo démocrates que le
secteur reste important mais on est plus
à l'ère des méga projets tels que seules
étaient disons pour les années 2000
jusqu'à 2014 2015 donc avant même la
pandémie le ralentissement économique
les variations de prix avait fait en
sorte que
l'ensemble du secteur avait commencé
deux grippés et les uns étaient
évidemment encore plus avec la pandémie
ce qui fait que le même si les prix du
pétrole sont meilleurs et que le même le
gouvernement albertain ici engrange les
redevances un peu plus importante bien
demeure pas moins le qu'on est plus dans
ces terres l'eau de construction de
nouveaux pipelines même si les
conservateurs en parle alors il ya quand
même un changement ici donc il faut
noter
on est rattrapé un peu par la réalité
aussi donc vers une automne il a quand
même présenté un plan vert il veut
imposer un prix sur le carbone et on
sait à quel point les conservateur
albertain était contre cette idée alors
est-ce que ça ça peut lui nuire là dans
cette campagne
ouais ça c'est une question qui se pose
comme vous le mentionnez
il ya peu de cette question la savoie en
six cerveaux de lui nuire il ya certains
conservateurs est effectivement qui en
avalent pause qui lui près ce qu'il voit
comme une trahison de la part des reines
auto qui se faisaient de champion du
secteur et l'eau qui arrive maintenant
avec
son propre son propre pour un clan vers
où il ya une taxation carbone même s'il
s'en défend donc ça évidemment c'est un
mal perçue par certains mais d'un autre
côté les la dynamique quand même changé
c'est à dire que le jugement de la cour
suprême qui est venu reconnaître la
légitimité de la proche libéral l'hiver
dernier fait en sorte que ça sacré comme
une soupape pour évacuer de la pression
pour les conservateurs pour arriver
comme et rien aux tôles le fait avec son
propre vin verres dans ce contexte là
peut-être que oui on va perdre quelques
voix du côté de concerts des
conservateurs à liberté et peut-être pas
tant que ça non plus et récupérer c'est
vous alors ailleurs au pays donc il ya
encore possibilité pour elle a noté que
ce plan vers la soie - deux majeurs
qu'on pourrait le croire il y avait une
petite hache en range plus de rouge du
tout sur la carte de l'alberta mais on a
vu justin trudeau et jack medsync faire
campagne
en alberta donc qui va aller chercher le
vote progressiste cette fois oui c'est
vrai qu'une autre pour le vote
progressiste
on a l'impression pour le moment que les
libéraux sont peut-être en avance
notamment du côté de bolton ou du côté
de quelqu'un égaré dans quelques
circonscriptions
seulement mais en même temps les néo
démocrates ne veulent pas laisser les
libéraux justement s'emparer du vote
progressiste et eux aussi veulent
envoyer un message à l'extérieur de
l'alberta comme quoi il ils sont le
parti les néo démocrates sont en mesure
justement de regrouper les progressistes
ailleurs au pays donc il ya cette note
lente les entre les deux formations le
qui ne feront pas de grands gains
électoraux par où plus de trois ou
quatre circonscriptions mais qui
symboliquement deviennent donc
importante et surtout pour les libéraux
si on veut former un gouvernement
majoritaire il faudrait éviter
d'embarrassantes situation dans laquelle
on se retrouvait en 2019 avec aucun
député en alberta et en saskatchewan au
ministre la plus tôt pour représenter la
région
je me tais ce que je me trompe ou est ce
qu'on n'a pas vu beaucoup monsieur jason
kenny dans cette campagne il avait fait
campagne en 2019 on le voyait partout et
là me semble qu'on le voit pas du tout
on ne voit pas du tout il est très très
discret pas très tendres vacances ou un
moment de ces trous en fait ce que il a
voulu éviter d'être un facteur dans le
début de cette campagne électorale parce
que lorsque monsieur trudeau monsieur
cinq sont venus en alberta ils ont ils
ont autant parler sinon plus de monsieur
qu'est née de sa gestion de la pandémie
et de son impopularité que deux erreurs
notées et c'est évidemment d'accoler
l'image de monsieur qu'est né
o'toole et c'est probablement pourquoi
monsieur trenet reste en retrait est
dans une position donc complètement
différente par rapport à l'élection de
médecine du côté de l'ontario lay up
folle on le voit pas tellement plus
alors comment ça se passe ça se présente
comment ça s'annonce pour le manitoba et
la saskatchewan
en saskatchewan ya vraiment peu de
possibilités de
changement la saskatchewan d'une
certaine façon est devenue la province
la plus conservatrice au pays je suis à
l'élection provinciale de l'automne
dernier du côté du manitoba et là c'est
un peu comme en alberta il faut regarder
du côté de winnipeg où il pourrait avoir
du changement le problème peut-être pour
les libéraux qui espère faire des gains
du côté de du mento boyd winnipeg c'est
que il semble y avoir certains sondages
qui montrent que des néo démocrates ont
repris un peu l'ascendant en termes de
pourcentage de voix dans ces provinces
est-ce que ça viendrait empêcher des
gains pour les libéraux c'est une
possibilité donc de se retrouver avec
une division du vote progressiste comme
ça pourrait être le cas d'ailleurs aussi
du côté de montanou calgary alors ça va
être intéressant à suivre puis à la
quatrième vague aussi sa frappe fort en
alberta ça pourrait venir brouiller les
cartes en terminant oui absolument
l'évolution de la pandémie surtout la
gestion de jason kenny de cette
quatrième vague pourrait se répercuter
sur les conservateurs fédéraux des
lamentos oui bon alors à suivre tout ça
on est quand même juste au début de
cette campagne même si ça va vite alors
merci de ce portrait des prairies merci
monsieur boyer c'est vrai que vous
remercie